하지만 곧 어떻게 하는지 알게 될 거예요. X와 Z
오류가 어떻게 작동하고 Quantum circuit 내에서 어떤 효과를 갖는지 더 잘 이해하려면, 이 오류들과 CNOT
gate 사이의 몇 가지 간단한 관계를 살펴보는 게 도움이 돼요. 이건 나중 강의에서도 유용할 거예요. 먼저 X 오류부터 시작해요.
X gate와 CNOT gate의 관계예요. 만약 CNOT의
타겟 qubit에 X gate를 적용한 다음 CNOT을 적용하면, 이는 순서를 바꿔서 CNOT을 먼저 하는 것과 동일해요.
반면에 CNOT의 제어 qubit에 X gate를 적용한 다음 CNOT을 적용하면, 단순히
순서를 바꿀 수는 없고 대신 두 qubit 모두에 X gate를 적용해야 해요. 원하신다면 이 모든 관계를
직접 확인해볼 수 있어요. 예를 들어 표준 기저 상태에 무슨 일이 일어나는지 생각해보면 돼요. Z
오류의 경우도 비슷한데, 제어와 타겟 qubit의 역할이 바뀌어요. 특히
CNOT의 제어 qubit에 Z gate를 수행하고 CNOT을 수행하면, 이는
CNOT 후에 Z gate를 수행하는 것과 같은 효과예요. 하지만 대신 타겟 qubit에 Z gate를 수행하면
이는 먼저 CNOT을 수행하고 두 qubit 모두에 Z gate를 적용하는 것과 동일해요. 마지막으로 이 모든
관계들은 각 방정식 양쪽의 gate 순서를 항상 바꿀 수 있다는 의미에서 대칭이에요.
이는 양쪽의 역행렬 또는 켤레 전치를 취하는 것과 동일한데, X, Z 및 CNOT
gate는 모두 자기 자신의 역행렬이기 때문이에요. 이제 위상 플립 오류와 이를 9 qubit Shore 코드로 감지하고 정정하는 방법을 살펴봐요.
인코딩 circuit가 있고, 9개의 qubit를 계속해서
세 qubit로 이루어진 세 블록으로 그룹화해서 생각할 거예요. 한 qubit에 Z 오류가 발생한다고 가정해요.
여기 표시된 것처럼요. Z gate와 CNOT gate에 대해 방금 관찰한 것을 사용하면,
이는 CNOT 이전에 두 개의 Z 오류, 하나는 제어 qubit에, 하나는 타겟 qubit에 발생하는 것과 동일해요.
이 오류들은 블록의 다른 CNOT과 교환 가능해요. 그래서 우리는
순서를 바꿀 수 있고 다음 결과를 얻어요. 하위 Z 오류는 0 상태에서 작동하기 때문에 아무것도 하지 않아요.
나머지를 밀어서 이 다이어그램을 얻어요. 우리가 발견한 건 중간 블록 어딘가의 Z 오류는
두 번째 인코딩 단계 이전에 중간 qubit에서 Z 오류가 발생하는 것과 동일하다는 거예요.
블록의 어느 qubit에 Z 오류가 발생해도 정확히 같은 방식으로 추론할 수 있어요. 블록 내 어느 qubit의 위상 플립도
내부 인코딩 이전의 해당 qubit의 위상 플립과 동일해요. Z 오류가 3비트 반복 코드에 어떻게 영향을 미치는지 생각해보면 실제로 꽤 직관적이에요.
그래서 Z 오류를 처리하는 한 가지 방법은 내부 코드를 디코딩한 다음 외부 코드를 사용해 Z 오류를 감지하고 정정하는 거예요. 외부 코드는
Z 오류를 정정할 수 있는 3비트 반복 코드의 수정된 버전이에요. 그래서 Z 오류가 정정되고
원하면 내부 코드로 재인코딩할 수 있어요. 또한 Z 오류를 제자리에서 정정할 수도 있어요.
디코딩하고 재인코딩하지 않고 그렇게 하는 거예요. 꽤 직관적이지만 어떻게 할 수 있는지 설명하려면
좀 더 공간이 필요해요. 내부 코드를 디코딩한다고 가정해 봐요.
그런 다음 외부 코드만의 세 qubit만 포함해서 이전과 같은 방법으로 외부 코드의 신드롬을 계산해요.
그런 다음 재인코딩해요. CNOT을 조금 단순화할 수 있고
방금 전에 관찰한 NOT gate와 CNOT gate 사이의 관계를 사용해서 그 작업을 도울 수 있어요.
이렇게 하면 CNOT 네 개를 절약할 수 있고 이게 우리가 얻는 circuit예요. 한 qubit에 Z 오류가 발생했다면
신드롬이 알려주는 건 이제 어떤 qubit에 Z 오류가 발생했는지가 아니라 어느 블록에 Z 오류가
발생했는지예요. 하지만 괜찮아요. 블록 내 어느 qubit에 Z 오류가 발생하든 상관없다는 걸 알고 있으니까요.
효과는 그 블록 내 세 qubit 모두에서 동일해요. 그래서 사실 그 블록의 어느 qubit에든 Z gate를 적용해서 Z 오류를 정정할 수 있어요.
어느 qubit에든 적용해도 돼요. 그런데 이건 오류 정정 코드에서 축퇴성이라고 불리는 것의 예시예요.
주어진 오류를 고유하게 식별하지 않고도 정정할 수 있는 거죠. 마지막으로 비트 플립과 위상 플립 오류가 모두 발생한다고 가정해 봐요.
같은 qubit에서 발생할 수도 있어요. 예를 들어
이 qubit에서 비트 플립과 위상 플립 오류가 발생한다고 가정해 봐요.
여기 있는 qubit에서요. 이 오류들은 완전히 독립적으로 감지하고 정정할 수 있어요.
사실 각 블록에서 비트 플립을 먼저 정정한 다음 위상 플립을 정정하든, 반대 순서로 하든 상관없어요.
이를 이해하기 위해 먼저 이 오류들의 순서는 상관없다는 걸 관찰해요. 원하면 뒤집을 수 있어요. 그 이유는
X와 Z가 교환 가능하기 때문이 아니에요. 교환 가능하지 않으니까요. X 곱하기 Z는 음의 Z 곱하기 X와 같아요.
하지만 이 경우 -1 인수는 전역 위상이기 때문에 효과가 없어요. 이제 전과 같이 Z 오류를 이동할 수 있고
이 시점에서, 먼저 각 블록에서 X 오류를 정정한 다음 Z 오류를 정정하면
두 오류 모두 정정될 거라는 게 명백해요. 반대로 어떤 이유로
Z 오류를 먼저 정정하기로 했다면, X 오류는 그 과정에서 아무런 영향을 미치지 않아요.
그건 사실이어야 해요. 첫 번째로 X 오류가 외부 코드의 신드롬을 계산하는 circuit의 모든 gate와 교환 가능하기 때문이에요.
두 번째로 정정을 위해 적용하는 Z gate와 X 오류 사이의 순서는
Z gate가 오류였을 때 주장했던 것처럼 상관없어요. 그래서 Z
오류를 정정할 수 있고, 그런 다음 X 오류를 제거하기 위해 각 블록을 정정할 수 있어요. 우리가 주장한 건 이 코드를 사용해서 qubit 중 어느 하나에서
X 오류, Z 오류 또는 둘 다를 정정할 수 있다는 거예요.
사실 그 이상의 오류도 정정할 수 있어요. 예를 들어 다른 블록에 있는 한 여러 X 오류나
최대 하나의 블록만 홀수 개를 받는 한 여러 Z 오류도 정정할 수 있어요. 하지만 앞으로 가장 관련성이 높은 건
어느 하나의 qubit에서 X 오류, Z 오류 또는 둘 다를 정정할 수 있다는 거예요. 강의의 마지막 부분에서
이것이 이 코드가 어느 하나의 qubit에서 임의적인 오류를 정정할 수 있다는 결론을 내리기에 충분한 이유를 알 수 있을 거예요.
임의적인 Quantum 오류를 고려할 강의의 마지막 부분으로 넘어가기 전에, Pauli 행렬로 표현된 오류가 무작위로 발생하는 경우
N qubit Shore 코드의 성능을 간단히
살펴볼 거예요.